- Hi everyone, good afternoon
or good evening depending on
where you're joining us in the country.
My name is Roy, and I'm here to give you
a quick overview of Camp Khan,
our new summer camp.
Quick agenda, here.
We're gonna do intros real quickly
talk about Camp Khan, the details
Kind of from the 30,000 foot view
all the way down to the ground level view.
Talk a little bit about these new courses.
Our Get ready for grade level courses,
and then have some time for questions.
We're gonna do all this
in about 30 minutes.
First, some intros.
As I mentioned, my name is Roy.
I am on the district partnership
team at Khan Academy.
I'm joined by my colleague
Patty Suquilanda.
She is also my teammate on
the district partnership team.
And Patty is going to be
moderating your questions.
And we'll reference
them and go through them
during the Q and A session.
Lauren Quan is on our marketing team.
She does a lot of our parent marketing.
So it's great to have Lauren here.
She's also going to be
monitoring questions.
So feel free to type those in
throughout the next 15 minutes.
We'll get to them either in the chat
or as we do the Q and
A a little bit later.
And please note that this
webinar will be recorded
and sent to you after this session.
You'll also see that there is a handout,
a one pager that just has
some details on Camp Khan
right on your GoToWebinar dashboard there.
It's titled, Camp Khan Article Webinar.
That's who we are.
And we don't have time to do intros
for Every single person in here,
but we have been talking with
and hearing from parents
throughout the school year,
particularly in the spring.
And what we heard from them was
this particular school
year was surprising.
It was unexpected.
It was overwhelming.
It was hectic,
it really it was just a lot.
And recognizing all those things
that the school year was,
we wanna first thank you
parents for being a caregiver,
and a teacher, a coach for your children.
A juggler really, of all
the different responsibilities you have.
And really just for being there,
for your family, for your children.
And it is with that in mind
that we started Camp Khan
which is our real first summer camp
that we're doing virtually, of course.
And we were trying to think of
what could be a way that
we could prepare students
for math next year.
Do some things that might help
to build their confidence.
And also do it in a fun
way that recognizes,
"Hey, it's still summer vacation,
even though this past school year
was all these different things
that we didn't really expect."
We wanna make sure that Camp Khan
does prepare students for math
and build a confidence
and also do it in a way
that's kinda flexible for
parents and for children too.
That's kind of like the 30,000 foot view
of what Camp Khan is.
I'm gonna just go a little bit lower
to say like the 15,000 foot view.
Give some details on Camp Khan.
So Camp Khan runs from June 22nd.
This Monday, we just launched.
You might have received an email
from us about it, actually.
And It'll go all the way to August 28th.
So a total of 10 weeks.
And it's intended for students
entering grades three
through 12 this fall.
And just like I mentioned before,
we wanna make this flexible for folks
so participants can join and stay whenever
and for however long.
And we also wanna make this
accessible for everyone.
So we've made sure that
it's free for everyone to.
Down below, you'll see
our four thinky pinkies.
These are like our mascot for Camp Khan.
And here are the ingredients of Camp Khan.
So one is the Get ready for math courses.
Get ready for grade level courses.
These are our math
courses that we're gonna
go into in a little bit more detail.
In addition, Camp Khan is
gonna deliver some strategies
for real self driven learning.
So thinking about how children,
students can really be
owners of their own learning.
And really drive their own learning.
And part we wanna make sure that
the parents aren't being
asked to do too much,
because we know you have done so much
throughout this school year.
And then also like I've mentioned,
we wanna make sure that Camp Khan
gives suggestions for fun
and motivational things
that you and your children
can do over the summer.
And we think if we combine all
those three things together,
that's gonna lead to sustained learning,
not just this Summer, but in years ahead.
All right, so how it works.
I'm gonna go a little bit more detail now.
I already mentioned this Monday,
you all should have received an email
just announcing Camp Khan.
And we sent that email
to all parents in the US,
all learners over the age of 13.
And all the US math teachers too.
From now until August 28
over that period of the next nine weeks,
we're gonna get weekly guidance
where learners can progress
on those get ready courses
that we're gonna go into
and receive some weekly
recommendations via email too.
And included in that weekly guidance
is just some tips and opportunities
to really recognize and
reflect on progress,
giving some ideas for
how you might celebrate
the effort your children are putting in
the learnings that they might
have throughout the year.
And again, making sure we
have some time for fun too.
That's a real quick overview.
If you have any additional questions,
I'm gonna refer you back to that one pager
that's in your handouts.
And this website on the bottom
here, Khan.co/CampKhan2020.
And we're also on social
under #CampKhan2020.
All right, I mentioned
the weekly recommendations and suggestions
that we're sending out.
Here's a rough outline
of what it looks like.
Each of our weekly emails will have
five suggestions along
three different topics.
Before I get into that,
I want to mention that all our messages
are available in Spanish.
And then those three topics are:
one, learning goals for your
Get ready for grade level courses;
second topic is learning tips
and they can be learning tips
about how to use Khan Academy.
How might you share progress
with a teacher or with an adult?
Or some reflection prompts
about how do you best learn.
What are some things that
you really like doing in a classroom;
and then the third topic
are these final motivational activities.
And these are gonna be taken
from our own content library.
So for instance, one of the things
that we're gonna suggest is our
Pixar in a box content.
Which is going to be a set
of courses and activities
that students can really do
to hone in on our imagination.
And then we're also gonna take
some fun and motivational activities
from some of our partner
organizations too,
who have great ideas for
how do you spend the summer?
And how do you spend a summer
not just in front of a screen,
but also outside and with
friends and with family.
For each of these topics,
we're gonna have clickable
videos on various weeks
where you can just write
directly in the Email,
view a video, or go to a partner resource.
Now, to get these emails,
there's no signup.
You don't need to do anything
other than have a Khan Academy
account of your parent.
And we'll also be sending
a similar but slightly
differently worded email
to learners who have spent any time
on our get ready for math courses.
All right, I feel like I've been talking
up these Get ready for grade
level courses quite a bit.
And wanna spend the next few minutes
just highlighting what those are.
So our get ready for math courses
are newly created math courses.
They were created or curated
in part because we heard from parents,
we heard from teachers who said,
"Hey, what can we do,
or what can our students
or children do between now
and whenever school reopens
that's gonna make sure that
they're ready to learn.
That they're ready to
hit the ground running
when school year 2021 begins."
What we did was go back
to all of our previous
or existing math courses,
and we just pulled the content
and the skills that we
think are most important
for a student to be successful
in the math class next year.
So if you have a child
going into fourth grade, for instance,
you will take the
get ready for fourth grade level course.
And in that get ready for
fourth grade level course,
you're gonna see skills
that may be from third
grade, from second grade.
The real foundational skills
that we find to be important
so that they can enter fourth grade
really confident and knowledgeable
to be successful in their
fourth grade math class.
I'm gonna show you just a few screenshots
of how you get to the get
ready for grade level courses.
First thing you wanna do
is get our newer website, Khanacademy.org.
Here you can either log in
or if you don't have khan
Academy accountant yet,
you can sign up and it's pretty easy.
You can do so with your
Google account, for instance.
Or you can create a new
username and password.
Once you're in the Khan Academy site,
and we're looking at this
from a student perspective.
So this is what your child might see.
They can on the top left
corner, go to Courses.
And from there, click that drop down.
And you can see on the bottom
right of my slide here,
there's going to be a list
of the entire Khan Academy library.
And this math, get ready courses,
they'll have a green new
button, to let you know.
Will show up and then just pick
the grade level that your child
will be entering in the fall.
Another way you can get to the
Get ready for grade level courses
is just by typing in or
clicking on this link directly.
And we'll be making these
slides available too
after the webinar.
Once you click into a get ready course,
you're gonna see a pop up that says,
"Show what you know!"
And there's gonna be an option
to start a course challenge.
Now, we recommend that
students or children
start with the course challenge
'cause it's gonna take them
through a set of skills
where they can demonstrate what they know,
and what they might just
brush up on a little bit.
And that course challenge
can also guide students
on what they should be doing
or what they might wanna
focus their time on.
Again, what they might wanna brush up on
after taking the course challenge.
And as your children are working to
the Get ready course,
you and they can track how they're doing
by the number of mastery points
that they earn, on the
top left hand corner.
We suggest usage of increasing progress
towards mastery by five to 10
percentage points each week.
As you see right here in the screenshot,
this student has made about 20%
of progress through the entire
Get ready for fifth grade course.
Reimagined five to 10
percentage points each week.
Camp Khan is 10 weeks.
By the end of 10 weeks,
if your child has followed
the weekly suggestion,
they hopefully will be at 100% completion
or getting pretty close to it.
All right, delivered a lot of
information pretty quickly here.
And we'll just break down some FAQ's,
some questions that we've
also heard from from parents.
So when we hear a question,
"Is Camp Khan right for my child?"
As we mentioned before,
Camp Khan is a free resource
for students entering
grades three through 12.
And it's a way to brush up on math
and also a way to look for fun
and motivational activities
throughout the summer.
We're hoping it's a low (murmurs).
And we're also hoping it's flexible.
So if parents want to join us
for the whole time, it's great.
If they wanna join us for
five weeks or three weeks,
that's totally fine too.
"What age is Camp Khan for?"
We are targeting Camp Khan
for learners entering grades three to 12
'cause that's where our
Get ready for grade level
courses are at math.
Now, younger students can also join us
for Camp Khan kids beginning July sixth.
These are for students
who are ages two through seven.
Again, younger kids who
might want to have that
exposure to learning activities
and fun activities this summer.
Third question we've heard is,
"What I have to do to
sign up and participate?"
Really signing up for Khan Academy
is most of what you
need to do as a parent.
Now, your child will get
these weekly notifications
with suggestions and recommendations
once they do any work on
our get ready courses.
And speaking of get ready courses,
our last question is,
"Which get ready course
should my child sign up for?"
I would suggest that children start
with a grade level that they're entering.
Now, if your child is exceptional at math
or is really doing some advanced math,
they might go to a
higher grade or assembly.
If they are struggling a little bit math,
we might recommend going
in it into a lower grade.
But broadly, generally speaking,
we would say the grade level course that
they should start with on get ready
is the one that we'll
be entering in the fall.
All right, so we've done a few FAQ's.
And so now we're gonna
turn it over to questions.
And this is where I'm gonna
talk with Patty a little bit.
And she's gonna share
some of the questions.
Hopefully we'll be able
to answer them here.
- Awesome.
Thank you so much, Roy,
for sharing that wonderful
information with us.
And just again, my name is Patty, here.
I get the pleasure to be on
the district partnerships team with Roy.
And so as part of the information
that Roy just shared with us,
we also wanna make sure we're grabbing
any of the questions you might have.
And so throughout the question area,
I also saw people were asking,
"Where can I get the slides?
Where can I look at the handout?"
And potentially, "Is this a webinar
that's gonna be recorded
and shared with us?"
So the answer to all those is, yes.
You will receive both the deck.
Slide deck or handout.
And you'll also receive a
recording of the webinar
via email after our session.
And then if you are in
your GoToWebinar screen,
there should be a little
tab that says handouts.
And that tab will have a PDF
called Camp Khan article webinar.
So if you click on that,
you'll then be able to see
all the information
that Roy shared as well.
So this would be a great time,
if you wanna add some pressing questions
that came up for you.
I can see a lot of folks are
adding questions as well.
And we're gonna start out with one
that I also noticed
was pretty common, Roy.
And it's specifically
coming to us from Carrie.
And Carrie has actually already started
using Camp Khan this week.
And so she's using it with her two kiddos.
One of them is in fifth
grade, and seventh grade.
And they're enjoying it.
And they're wondering a little bit about
what the pace should be for a student
to kind of move through the content.
So she's saying she wasn't really sure
what time to aim for.
"Is there a recommendation or a time
that students should spend
weekly on Camp Khan?"
- Yeah, great question Carrie.
And thanks for getting started
on the Get ready courses.
And hope your girls are
enjoying the courses.
We recommend probably about
two or three hours per week
on the Get ready for grade level courses.
Now, you can split those out,
an hour a day for two days.
Or you can say, "I'm gonna do 30 minutes
or 45 minutes a day
for four or five days."
That's totally up to you.
Again, we want this to be
as flexible as possible
given your schedules.
And then in addition to
the hours spent per week,
we also recommend that students
make about five to 10
percentage point increase
in their mastery progress.
- Awesome, thank you.
I think that will be
really helpful for parents
as they're nudging and
encouraging students
to work through their Get
ready for grade level courses.
So a little bit more
on the logistics, Roy,
just to make sure
parents are really clear.
And anyone who's joining us on the line.
Stitcher wants to know, "Is
Camp Khan limited to math?"
- Yeah, great question.
So Camp Khan, the work that students
will be going through is limited
to the Get ready for grade level courses
which are in math.
At the same time,
we're hoping that Camp Khan
is more than just math.
We're hoping it's an opportunity
for students to build confidence.
It's an opportunity for students
to have a little bit of
fun because it is summer.
So we're going to be infusing
those suggestions for progressing in math
on those Get ready for
grade level courses.
Along with say, some reflection prompts
that asks students to really think about,
"How do I learn best?
What can I do when I
find myself struggling
with learning something?
How do I feel when I
finally do learn something
that's really challenging."
So some of those learning reflections
and prompts that's gonna
build their confidence
and awareness as a learner.
And then also some fun activities,
like getting outside and
going on nature walks.
Or doing virtual tours through museums
that are offering these
great opportunities.
Or looking through some of our content
like Pixar in a box or
Imagineering in a box.
It's really about creativity.
- Thank you for sharing that.
Yeah, I think it's great
to make sure there's a holistic set
of opportunities for students.
Awesome.
So the next question
comes to us from Jeffrey.
And Jeffrey wants to get super clear,
"Do parents or students
pick the course level?
And can they switch if needed?"
- Great question, Jeffrey.
Students will naturally
pick the course level.
Though we went past that parents
are just sitting alongside their child
as they pick the course level.
We do recommend that students
at least start with the grade level
that they're gonna be
entering in the fall.
And your second question,
they can always switch if they want.
They can always click in the other classes
in the other Get ready
for grade level courses.
Depending on whether they find
the material too challenging or too easy.
- Great, I think that flexibility is key
for students and for parents as well.
So let's switch the view a little bit
and think more about
the student themselves,
who's gonna be working on this content.
And so when we think about
the design of the courses,
are they getting students to catch up
on their current grade level?
And this question is
specifically from (indistinct).
So just wannabe clear, (indistinct).
We're answering your question.
"Are the Get ready classes designed
to help students catch up to
their current grade level?
Or can they also be used
for advanced learners,
and how could they be used
for advanced learners?"
- Yep.
Again, another great question.
The creation of the Get ready courses
was more to get students caught up.
So more to your first question.
We wanna make sure again,
that if you do the get
ready for let's say,
fifth grade course, you're
gonna enter fifth grade
ready to learn the fifth grade math.
For advanced learners, will they be good?
I think the get ready courses
could potentially be good courses
for advanced learners too.
And I'm thinking particularly for,
if we have some middle school students,
middle school mathematician who
are really kind of chomping at the bit
to know a little bit
about high school math.
Or to think, "I wonder how
well I would do in algebra?"
They could take those
high school level courses,
just to get a sense of
what they would need
to be successful in those courses.
So short answer is for advanced learners,
I would recommend even
going on to grade levels
above where a student is going
to be entering in the fall.
- That's a great.
That's a great suggestion.
And as we're thinking about
students potentially looking
or reviewing content and
potentially getting stuck, right?
We know that that happens.
And that's okay when you're learning math.
So how could kids seek help?
And this is a question from Nepor,
who wants to know...
Or references that you mentioned, Roy
that there's gonna be an
option to seek guidance.
So how could students get help?
- Yep, great question Nepor.
In each of our exercises in Khan Academy,
there are videos students can watch
that gives them a teaching
of what the concept is.
And in addition, there are hints
that will give students
kind of step by step
how you solve this problem.
We always recommend that students
watch the video first
'cause that probably
just about the concept.
And we've also seen some students
just watch the videos before
they even start on their problems.
In addition to the videos,
if student is really stuck
they can always just click the hint
under each question and the hint will be
a step by step solving
of that particular question
the student is seeing.
And we think this is a
great way for students to
again, take a little bit of ownership
or more ownership in their learning.
And also, we hope this is a way
where a student is constantly
gonna be asking you the parent
for help every time you might be stuck.
- That's really helpful.
And a similar question from Deanna,
relate it to that, right?
Like, "Do parents need
to be hands on helping?
Or is it fairly simple for
kids to navigate on their own?"
So maybe just sharing a little bit more
about how kids can navigate on their own.
- Yeah, great question.
The question of whether or how much
parents should be hands on,
we leave it totally up to the parent.
Again, we want Camp Khan and our courses
to be pretty flexible and ready to promote
self driven learning but from the student.
So for a student when they
get on the Khan Academy,
we do recommend starting
with that course challenge.
And then the exercises,
we always recommend that
follow a blue button.
So there's a blue Start button,
or a blue Continue button.
And once you click on those
then students will get
underway on their exercises.
And then once in the exercises,
they can start looking at those videos
and viewing those hints.
And then if they're stuck,
we can recommend that they asked
maybe an older sibling.
Or they ask another adult
in the in their household,
and then eventually we might ask that
they reach out to the parent.
- I think that's great scaffolding.
I think very similar to the way teachers
have the three before me rule
sometimes in the classroom.
So maybe parents caregivers out there
can do the three before me,
and the first one can definitely be Khan
and the resources that you mentioned, Roy.
- Yeah.
- Similar to that,
I think as part of being
a parent, Telacy asks,
"How do we as parents see
the progress of our students
and what they're learning?"
- Yeah, then a great question.
A couple ways you can do this.
One is to just have the student
have a child show you
what they're working on,
and how much progress they're making.
Another way, and we're gonna
send us an upcoming email
is to join your student
account and watch...
Not watch I guess, and see their progress
on the Get ready for grade level course.
So this is gonna require the parent
to add the child's account
and then for the child to
approve (murmurs) the parents.
So there's gonna be a little bit
of back and forth so
that the parent can see
what the child is working on
and how they're doing on it.
And we're gonna send
those instructions out
in an upcoming email.
- Great, that'll be
really, really helpful.
We have another question
from Kimberly asking,
"Can my child use their
district Khan Academy account?
Or do they have to create
a new student account?"
- Yeah, students can use existing accounts
and just go and start working
on their get ready course.
They don't need to create a
new account for our Camp Khan.
- That's great.
That's very helpful.
We have now a question from April.
And we probably have
room for a couple more.
So for sure, please keep
asking your questions.
This is from April, who says,
"Do you have any example
of the fun activities
that go in conjunction
with the Get ready courses?
Who makes the clickable videos?"
- Yeah, great question.
So like I mentioned, the fun activities
will be coming some from
our content library.
So I mentioned our Pixar in a box,
our Imagineering and a box.
And those are kind of
videos and activities
that are meant to spark
children's imagination.
We also have content
from our growth mindset
library for instance.
Which is really meant to explain
the brain science behind getting smarter.
So we see those as more kind
of motivational content.
So that's one side of that,
of the final motivation activities.
They're gonna come from us.
Another part of the answer
is from our partner organizations.
So we will be partnering with schools
like wide open schools
that have great suggestions
and activities on things
families can do outdoors
during this summer.
For instance, taking a nature walk.
We'll work with other organizations
about virtual tours that students
can take during this summer.
So those are just some examples
of what we'll be including
in the final activity
section of our weekly emails.
- That's really helpful.
Great.
We have another question from Louise.
Louise says, "I'm ready
Grandma helping my grandson.
We're at different locations.
Any suggestions?"
- Thanks, Louise.
And thanks for thinking
about your grand son
even though he may not
be right there with you.
Our suggestion is to
pass along the article
that's in this webinar, that handout.
And there'll be some directions
or for getting started.
Or to have them get on Khan Academy.
And there are links to sites,
specifically the Camp Khan details
that a student, any student who
wants to get on the website,
they'll have directions there.
And then they can get started
just by following directions on our site.
- Wonderful.
And then I think this will
be our last question, Roy.
Which came up a little bit
with some other participants.
So this is specifically from
Lim and a couple others.
"I would like to know
how the Get ready courses
are different than the
other grade level courses
you already have out there."
- Yeah.
Thanks for that question Lim.
And I apologize for not
being clear about this
during the webinar.
The Get ready courses,
let's say in our get ready
for fifth grade course level
it's actually pulling
from our math courses.
Our regular grade level
courses in fourth grade,
in third grade, and second grade.
So the get ready for fifth grade course
is actually containing skills
and content from grade
levels below fifth grade
that have been identified
as the most crucial,
most important things to know
before you start fifth grade.
So in other words,
the difference between
the Get ready for fifth
grade course content
and the fifth grade course content
is the fifth grade course content
is going to be what your
child learns in the fall.
The Get ready for fifth
grade course content
is gonna be the content
that's gonna prepare your child
to be successful to learn
fifth grade math in the fall.
So I hope that distinction was helpful.
- Yeah, I think that
will be really helpful
to a lot of folks.
And I think Roy, that'll
be it for our questions.
So if you wanna wrap us up.
- Great.
Thanks very much again
for all of your time.
We will send out these slides.
And in addition, please visit our website
and you will get an email
with the resources here
and a survey link.
So please fill out the survey link
that'll help us to improve our webinars
and also continue to hear from you all.
Thanks very much.